>>Sparky: Oh what a beautiful time for everything
to freeze up.
Okay, good afternoon everybody and welcome,
once again, to the Android Developers Office
Hours.
This is the EMEA edition where we are answering
any and all questions Android developer, you
know, for all of you who are awake during
the middle of the afternoon in European time
zones.
I'm Sparky, I'm based in Munich, Germany and
I'm also joined by Nick and Rich and is that
Matt in London?
>>All: Hi everybody!
>>Sparky: We're here and welcome you to the
post IO resumption of our regularly scheduled
weekly office hours.
So with that let's see who's in the hangout
and what, what did you think of Google IO?
[baby coos in background] and Johanni, what
did you think of Google IO?
Did you see any of it?
>>Rich: He did but his microphone's not turned
on so in the meantime hey Al, how ya doing?
[Laughter]
>>Al: I'm doing great.
>>Sparky: Johanni's representing the silent
majority.
>>Al: Today he's gonna bring all his questions
to you in sign language.
Um, I thought it was cool.
It's always a great event.
Went last year, went this year, it's always
good to see stuff.
It's always a little disappointing for us
European developers to see U.S. only products
but that's the way things go, that's the world
we live in.
So, I've had a lot of fun with the queue though.
>>Rich: U.S. products like the Jellybean rollout
which is happening across Europe today.
>>Al: U.S. products like the Glass Developers
Kit had me grumbling for days.
[Laughter]
>>Sparky: So which is worse, is it worse to
be a European with no expectation of ever
getting these things or is it worse to be
an American transplanted into to Europe knowing
that because of where my account was created
I have access to some of these things but
when I try to actually navigate to their pages
it says this doesn't work here?
>>Al: I think you're in the worse position.
[All talking]
>>Rich: Sparky in his first world problems.
[Laughter]
[Mumbling]
>>Nick: So, Al, you've been on the Nexus queue
I see with some of your posts on Google blast?
>>Al: Yep.
>>Nick: What did you manage to do so far?
One of my favorite lines at the key note is,
what did it say, eminently hackable?
>>Al: It's incredibly hackable.
Um, you can unlock the boot loader so once
the source code hits the Android opens the
project, you're gonna be able to build your
own phone anywhere and do what you want with
it.
I've had it running pretty much most of the
major Android apps including the Playstore,
Chrome, uh, you name it, it'll do it.
It's just a case of working out a good user
interface to it.
If you hook up a USB on the go, micro USB
to a USB host adaptor you can hook up mice,
keyboards to it, it really is one of those
devices that it's gonna have a big story to
tell, it's just up to everybody to see how
they wanna use it.
In some ways I think it's nice that there's
no guidance.
It's a case of here's a device, do something
cool with it and it'll be interesting to what
everyone comes up with.
>>Nick: Very cool.
So you're basically just using ADV install.
Is it just like pushed onto the device and
once you've got launch on there it's pretty
easy to do some things?
>>Al: Absolutely.
Yeah, once you've got ADV install to install
the apps you can switch the micro USB across
the USB onto the go one, plug a mouse in and
you've got yourself a control method.
So you can do, I was playing Angry Birds on
it using the mouse, um, you can do pretty
much anything you want because the media APIs
are the same, video APIs are the same, there's
no special features or special APIs for the
queue it's just a case of if it's an Android
app you can run it on there as long as you
don't rely on things like multi touch or a
camera.
>>Nick: So have you had any, have you had
a look at the buildup prop to see what prop
it reports, do you have any problems installing
apps if they, say there were a touch screen
or anything like this?
>>Al: Um, I haven't looked at the buildup
doc prop but a lot of the ones, a lot of the
default properties mean you can use a mouse
instead of a touch screen.
Multi touch is a big no no.
If anything needs multi touch that won't work.
And of course things like the camera, there's
no camera in it but a lot of Android apps
come in straight off the bat.
It's just about making sure the experience
on a TV screen is usable and it's reasonable
for the size of screen.
[Pause]
>>Al: I think London are frozen again.
>>Sparky: So since you mentioned the key note,
I didn't see much of the key note live because
I was working out in the lobby but I've seen
some of the playback and I think my favorite
comment by far is when the sky divers are
on their way down and I think it was Sergey
said something like, "How's this for a hangout
on air?"
[Laughter]
>>Nick: Yeah, that was an extremely cool demo.
It's definitely one of those that's gonna
go down in history.
>>Rich: Yeah I think my favorite comment is
someone just said, "We've won the internet."
[Laughter]
>>Al: Was that you won it was a prize and
it's being presented to Sergey next week?
>>Rich: You've won one internet [laughter]
>>Rich: Anyway, IO was like weeks ago, now,
like uh
[Pause]
>>Al: Done, built.
Posted up some instructions, if anyone's having
trouble building on a Mac have a look at my
Google Plus stream I've put up how you can
build it on OSX live on the latest X code
version.
>>Nick: Brilliant.
Thanks for that.
That's very kind of you.
>>Al: Yeah, it's all there.
All the goodness is there for anyone to play
with.
>>Sparky: So have you built it as a ROM that
runs on any of your other devices yet?
>>Al: I have it running as a Rom on my Galaxy
Nexus.
I custom built IOS P ROM.
>>Rich: Nice, good work Al.
>>Al: Davey Q and the guys in his team do
a great job of merging in all the stuff internally
and they always make sure it's buildable on
the device when they release it.
So it literally was a case, for me, of typing
in a couple of extra commands and presto,
I got myself a working Rom.
>>Rich: That's excellent.
I love these kinds of things.
[Pause]
>>Rich: So we have loads of questions this
week in the moderator.
So unless we have any direct questions from
our hangout to kick off with from Charles,
Johanni or Al, we'll start looking through
the moderator.
>>Al: I was gonna put one out to Matt.
Cause I see he's sitting there quietly in
the background.
[Echo]
>>Al: Just a quick question, is there recommendation
of how think developers in second screen in
applications?
>>Rich: Sorry, could you just repeat that
we had a bit of feedback on this end?
>>Al: Sure, no worries.
Is, are there any recommendations about implementing
the second screen features of Google TV in
Android applications and should developers
be looking to create separate apps or should
they look into, look to use second screen
as a feature of their app when their apps
also running on a Google TV device?
>>Matt: So I think [inaudible] goes down the
route of promoting a single APK but I think
a lot of developers are kind of getting to
a point where if the content really doesn't
make sense to be the same on both, they probably
would go down the separate APK route which,
I think, it does depend on the app.
So most do have a single APK and [inaudible]
but essentially they're gonna go down two
very different routes even though they're
gonna be working with each other, then, yeah,
just go for multiple APK, I mean, it's whatever
makes sense, I think.
It deviates so much from the phone, tablet
realm that you've really just got to think
what's gonna make your life as a developer
a little bit easier.
>>Al: Cool, thanks.
>>Rich: Okay.
>>Johanni: Hey guys I just have one question,
if you don't mind me asking quickly.
>>Rich: Sure.
Go ahead.
>>Johanni: It's just to do with the top developer
badge.
Um, you may or may not be able to answer this
but we have a client who has an app in the
Playstore that's very popular, it's got about
two and a half million or so downloads.
And they were sort of wondering how they could
earn this top developer badge.
If there was any formal procedure or just
purely a case of you guys in the developer
relations team pick developers occasionally?
>>Rich: So it's not down to us at all in the
developer relations team.
If you have a look through Dan and Ian's video
from IO you can see where the selections are
made, they're made deep in an underground
lair, made deep under Mountain View by the
editorial team.
Occasionally we do recommend developers for
them to review but for the most part the scouring
on the Playstore themselves looking for people
who look likely to earn the top developer
badge.
>>Nick: It tends to be a bit of a pipeline
as well.
It's the same criteria as featuring, you know,
we have people looking out across the market
for good apps, watching the trending lists
and so on.
As well as developers that develop relations
directly and so that feeds into a pipeline
for that featuring and it's generally those
kind of apps which get narrowed down to apps
that we might want to make editors choice
or a developer whose got a great track record
of making high quality applications which
might get top developer.
>>Johanni: Okay.
>>Nick: So it's the same kind of pipeline,
really the same kind of process.
Who's the, what's the app of interest?
>>Johanni: It's the Sky Scanner app.
>>Nick: This guy's got other flight tracking
>>Johanni: Yeah.
>>Nick: Okay.
>>Al: From what you guys said it sounds like
it would need multiple apps from a developer
rather than just one.
Is that the right way to think?
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Rich: You stand a better chance if you've
got multiple, high rated, lots of in store
kind of apps, but you are gonna get developers
who do get the badge with one application.
I think if you look through some of the big
names out there you'll see if they have the
top developer badge.
We do use it to signify times when it's a
trusted developer as well as a top developer.
>>Johanni: Okay, so there's nothing that,
that [inaudible] could do to sort of put themselves
out there as looking to have the top developer
badge?
>>Rich: I guess they just have to [inaudible]
[Laughter]
>>Johanni: Fair enough.
>>Rich: There's no formal process or submission
process or anything like that.
>>Johanni: Okay great.
Well, thanks for that.
>>Rich: This is as close as it gets.
Okay, let's head off to the moderator then.
We've got a lot to get through in the next
49 minutes.
Do you wanna take over Sparky?
Someone just mentioned that there's a feedback,
a 3 second audio feedback, are anyone else
in the hangout hearing that?
>>Al: I had it briefly when I was asking my
question when you guys asked me to repeat
it but I have not heard it since then.
>>Rich: Anyone else having trouble with the
audio?
I'll just leave it off speakers and microphones,
how about that?
This may be the last of the hangouts we do
from this room.
We're hoping to shift to a hangout studio
very shortly, either next week or soon after
so there won't be, the quality of the hangout
should improve, no end, that's just the quality
of the video not just the quality of the content,
obviously there's no improving perfection.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: Sparky, do you want to handle a bit
of the moderator?
>>Sparky: Yeah, I don't know what's, I don't
know what's going on, you guys don't seem
to be having the feedback anymore but I I'm
still getting it.
[Echo]
>>Al: I'm getting it now from Sparky.
[Echoes]
>>Rich: Okay, just check what windows you've
got open; if you've got the YouTube window
open as well we've had some issues before
which caused us to drop out.
He's got to turn his camera around.
Hey Doran, it's good to see you there in the
hangout.
Thanks for coming along.
Do you have any questions for us today?
>>Doran: Hey, I just joined.
I'm new; I'll start by listen more and [inaudible]
[Laughter]
>>Rich: Okay, come in with a killer Android
technical question for us.
>>Doran: No, no.
I just started getting the hang of the hangout
now, it's my first experience.
So, wow.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: Your first at a Google hangout.
>>Doran: Yeah.
>>Rich: Well, this one's live.
You should know that this is live on air with
YouTube, we should probably mention that.
We usually do a disclaimer at the start of
each of these saying that this is hangout
on air.
It's live on YouTube for anyone to watch and
also during the hangout we won't make any
announcements about road maps or product releases.
[Pause]
>>Rich: So I think Sparky is back with us
no.
>>Sparky: I am back with you and you were
exactly right.
It was the YouTube window; I didn't even realize
it was up because it was hidden behind my
hangout window.
>>Rich: It's so much better.
>>Sparky: Yeah, let's see if I can find that
moderator.
Just a sec, I had to close that combined Omnibus
window so now I'm just bringing up the bare
moderator.
>>Rich: Right, [inaudible]
>>Sparky: Alright, operated question.
It says, "VLC for Android developer here,
from Paris France," Bonjour!
[Laughs]
>>Sparky: "Do you plan to support the distribution
of the multiple APK architecture based for
a single application?"
It says, "We don't wanna have just a generic
20 meg APK out of which you only pick one
architecture."
So this is, this is a surprisingly popular
request, I think, given that there's hardly
any devices out there that aren't [inaudible]
based.
But, you know, anything that just runs in
dalvik doesn't need to select based on architecture.
So it's really only for APKs that have a native
component and I don't think we've announced
anything in that regard.
So going back to what you were saying
>>Nick: I think we've got some questions in
the moderator which we may have tackled last
week with this being one of them where yeah
we this feedback that you wanna switch AVI
to multiple APK and yeah, it's on the roadmap
but don't know when.
But thank you for the feedback; we'll feed
that through to the developers and [inaudible]
team.
>>Sparky: So, let's see, next one, "My widgets
stop interacting with my application.
One of the buttons is really simple it has
a pending intent to start the application's
main activity.
What could stop a pending intent from working
and basically how can you get some sort of
inspection or debugging insight on pending
intents?
He says, "Can you get log cat info?"
I would presume that means or anything else.
I guess my first question is are you doing
anything to, say, refreshing the pending intent
when, say either when it fires?
Like if you click the button and then it fires,
are you refreshing it with code?
Or if you're leaving your activity and then,
basically if you're doing anything that restarts
your app or activity are you refreshing your
pending intent at any time.
Do you guys have anything to offer on that?
>>Rich: You know, I mentioned, we had this
one last week as well, we're gonna have to
ditch down to, I think the first one we didn't
answer was the [inaudible] master builder
question cause we don't have your access to
the moderator.
The other thing we did say last week was if
you're debugging your application and you
keep pushing new variances of it to the handset
from your development environment then you
have to revamp the widget each time as the
widget would become disassociated with the
application.
But, other than that, in a production environment
it shouldn't be happening.
The pending intent should remain associated
with the application [inaudible].
>>Sparky: Do you know of anything, like any
particular events that cause a pending intent
to get dropped or obsoleted or something?
>>Rich: No.
>>Sparky: Oh, okay.
>>Al: If the intent, the pending intent is
taking place and not received by the application,
there should be a message in [inaudible] cat
that says that the intent has been fired even
if the application has not received it.
>>Rich: Yeah, I agree.
I was just admiring the little jellybean statue
in the background from the jellybeans.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: Alright, so let's move on then.
We've got a couple more just slightly further
down.
Did you get an answer for the blur mask filter
question, Sparky?
>>Sparky: For the which one?
>>Rich: blur mask filter?
>>Sparky: Not yet.
I only, I reported it as, I filed it as a
bug this afternoon and of course the Mountain
View guys haven't come online yet so they
haven't seen it.
>>Rich: Excellent.
That's the kind of power you have when you
file a question inside of the office hours.
So the question was, "Android Blur Mask Filter
has no effect on canvas dot draw oval, or
any other shape while the text is blurred
on quality report."
Apparently, there's a bug there.
>>Sparky: Also, my comment there is out of
date.
I took the information that he posted to stack
overflow and I made an app that uses his code.
>>Rich: Fantastic.
>>Sparky: Yeah, I attached that to my bug
so the guys on the Android team should have
no excuse to say, "Oh, we couldn't reproduce
it here."
>>Man in hangout: I'm sorry that is, I am
[inaudible] that is my bug.
I've been actually tinkering with it for over
a week and I just couldn't figure out what
was wrong and some other guy has posted that
it would perfectly on Gingerbread.
But I'm not sure if Gingerbread has hardware
acceleration or does it?
>>Rich: No, no it doesn't.
>>Man in hangout: That's why it worked on
Gingerbread.
Thank you.
>>Rich: Yeah, so, on Ice Cream Sandwich or
Honeycomb above you can turn off hardware
acceleration if you wanna make sure it is
the hardware acceleration cause it is possible
that it is.
And then some of the hardware acceleration
is used with, is fixed again in Jellybean.
So you may just need to turn it off for Honeycomb
and Ice Cream Sandwich if you find it is hardware
acceleration related.
>>Nick: And also, a note on that, if you set
your target API at 15 for Ice Cream Sandwich
then you'll automatically turn on hardware
acceleration so you might not have realized
you turned it on.
>>Man in hangout: Well, it was intended to
be because it's a heavy application.
It just computes a lot of loads and everything.
>>Rich: Yeah, you'll definitely have to play
with the hardware acceleration.
>>Nick: The hardware acceleration's not gonna
help with complication stuff it's just gonna
help with [inaudible]
>>Man in hangout: Right.
>>Nick: For those kinds of things you might
wanna look at run script.
>>Rich: Yeah, okay.
>>Nick: Yeah, the next question in the moderator
says, "The Spotify app and other music apps
have added cover arts, images and playback
controls on the lock screen.
Can you point me to the API or tutorial to
amend this myself?"
Sparky's posted a [inaudible] stack load [indistinct]
but the answer remote control client.
>>Sparky: Yeah, basically the, there's some
information out there that was actually provided
by the guy who publishes, is it called widget
unlocker or widget locker?
>>Nick: This isn't that though, this is talking
about the official remote control client.
So as of Ice Cream Sandwich there's, this
is what Spotify and the built-in music app,
and a number of apps like TuneIn radio, use.
There's an official way on the Android like
stop lock screen to post the LMR and images
and so on and the playback tools.
So he needs to look at the Android dot media
dot dot remotecontrolclient [indistinct] to
do that.
I don't know that it's a sample code after
that, do you know, Sparky?
Has it been added to the random music playback
app?
>>Sparky: I haven't taken a look at it.
>>Nick: Okay.
I'm not sure that it will be but if you take
a look at the remote control client class
then you can come back to us here if you have
any further questions on that.
>>Al: There's a bit of a sample code, actually,
in the API doc to remote control client class
so hopefully that will be enough to get him
going.
>>Nick: Yeah.
[Pause]
>>Nick: Should we get to the next question?
>>Rich: Sure, I'm just looking through the
comments on the Google Plus thread.
There's quite a few comments about how to
start up as a brand new Android developer
and how do you install the tool chain?
Apparently the it may, the documentation may
have got out of sync with the latest Android
developer tools.
Um, we did notice this but we were doing code
laps at Google IO this year and the first
part of the code lap is to import the project
into eclipse and we started the code lap at
the same time as they release Android developer
tools 20 which changes the eclipse import
process.
So, actually, no one can complete step 1.1
of the code lap but the steps on the developer
Android dot com at the start for installing
eclipse should be all up to date so we'll
get that checked out if they're not.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Sparky: I would also say that unless your
app is really complex you can go a long, long
ways not importing the project.
My typical approach in Eclipse is either to
start a project with an external source rather
than importing it or failing that, or possibly
in combination with that, I can just create
a basic project with the Hello World app and
then copy the source, the res folder, the
source and res folders and the Androidmanifest
dot xml into the new project and just use
those and just go from there.
>>Nick: Sneaky, well used [indistinct].
>>Rich: Still the application needs [inaudible]
>>Sparky: Yeah, I've been and Eclipse user
for a long, long time and I've always been
pretty suspicious of any import wizards related
to Eclipse which is why I kind of learned
early to just copy files into a template app
[Laughs]
>>Sparky: And go from there.
>>Rich: Alright, do you wanna hit up the next
question then?
>>Nick: We got a question from [inaudible]
and it says, "Is developing for the latest
API level, will make my app run on all Android
devices, say 13 or 12?"
So I'm gonna interpret that, I think there's
two things you can say when developing the
latest API level, you need to bear in mind,
there's the API level you're building against,
so you know, that's the version you're looking
at real time.
And then there's also the attribute in your
manifest with target API level.
So those two things can differ but I would
argue they are the same.
So I would say that you always want to set
both of those to build against and target
to the latest version of the Android release
which you know about and you've tested your
application on.
And then you can set a different min STK which
is the minimum version of Android on which
it will run.
So by setting those two things, that defines
the level of devices that your app will run
on.
So you need to be aware when you set them
different you're basically signing a contract
saying I promise not call any new APIs on
any old releases and this is actually what
I gave a code lap on in Google IO.
If you go to developers dot Google dot com/IO
and look in the code lap section there's one
about building backward possible Android apps
and from there you'll be able to find my slides
and a code lap there as well.
So I hope that answers your question.
>>Sparky: I would just reinforce on that that
your target API level is not the maximum that
your app will run on, it's simply the maximum
who's features your app already knows about
at the time you write it.
But any device that has backwards compatibility
is just about all will do, even on a newer
OS will run it just fine.
So don't be afraid to put your target STK
as high as you can and then your min STK to
the lowest you'll support.
>>Al: It's also probably worth mentioning
that the min STK, it is a filtering market
so if you set it too high some users won't
be able to see it if they have an older device
so it's best to check that the features you're
using really do need the API level, if it
can be done with API level of 2-4 it's worth
dropping min STK down.
>>Sparky: Right and for certain, if you're
looking for, you know, monetary justification,
you know, it's really nice if you can go back
to 2.2 or 2.1 to get, if you wanna get the
long tail go back to 1.6 but you can cover
like 95 percent of your possible market place
by going back to 2.1.
>>Al: Was there any update on recommended
methods for using reflection to optimally
degrade features so you can support older
versions of devices or older versions of Android
as well as having features of the latest stuff?
>>Rich: I prefer to API gate things these
days, there used to be a need for reflection
in 1.5 and 1.6 but as of 2.0 you can include
code inside the class files that wouldn't
be able to run on the system as long as you
don't actually run it.
>>Nick: Well, actually, I don't think there
was ever really a need for reflection unless
your manually building against, you know,
linking against the lower API level and then
trying to invoke later added APIs, that's
the only case I can think of where you need
reflection.
The issue with the pre 2.0 class load is to
blow up, if you try to incorp classes which,
you know, are running a Cupcake device, you
can get around that with a factory pattern
which are much nicer than the reflection,
in my opinion cause you still get [inaudible].
>>Al: Okay, cool.
[Pause]
>>Rich: Okay.
>>Nick: So there's some chat going on in the
G plus plus [inaudible] about getting started.
Matt Storms is asking for some pointers on
getting started.
So it sounds like it's not really getting
started with Android it's getting started
in Java programming is what it sounds like.
Does anyone have any top picks of great places
to get jump start your Java development?
There's Code Academy I've heard good things
about, not used it myself but I heard that's
pretty useful for new starters.
>>Matt: [inaudible]
>>Nick: What was that Yani?
>>Johanni: There's millions of tutorials on
Google [inaudible]
>>Nick: There's a lot of tutorials I guess
it's just picking good ones.
>>Sparky: On actually a lot of the, a lot
of the introductory Android sample apps and
tutorials also give a pretty good sort of
gentle introduction to Java especially the
relevant bits.
>>Johanni: [inaudible]
>>Matt: Do you have plans to get a step by
step tutorial going?
>> Nick: [inaudible]
>>Matt: Yeah, that might be a good place to
look
[Mumbling]
[Pause]
>>Nick: Alex is asking, "When, oh, when will
I finally get the new developer console?"
[Laughter]
>>Nick: I'm so excited.
Like we said we can't really talk about dates
cause they'll probably change and they'll
be wrong and we'll look silly.
So all I can say is you keep doing the right
thing, signing up for the preview, the team
is working as hard as they can to get it out
as soon as possible.
>>Rich: Well, done in signing up for the preview
as well.
[inaudible] maxed out during the IO presentation
that announced the preview and it was live.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: So if you managed to sign up that's
good because if you try to get to the link
now it just says Thank you but we've already
filled our quota.
So you will be one of the first people to
see and get it, it looks like, when the rollouts
do happen.
[Pause]
>>Rich: We've got Trevor who
>>Sparky: We can hear Trevor so maybe he would
like to say hello and actually tell us what's
on his mind towards Android development.
>>Nick: He's the strong silent type.
[Laughter]
>>Sparky: Stunned him into silence.
>>Nick: [Inaudible] our colleague in Sidney,
so it's what 10 o'clock there?
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Nick: He's got a young baby though so he's
probably up at all hours.
Making an excellent point about that backward
compatibility chat we were having earlier
saying that Lint helps you out so yeah, very,
very much so.
I think one of the reasons people used to
change the level of Android they're building
against is just to make sure they weren't
provoking any new APIs, it's now kind of obsoleted
by the fact that you can use Lint to stats
and analysis of your code and it'll give you
this new API warning if you're trying to invoke
an API that was introduced later than whatever
you set your min as, your min API level, so
that's a really good point.
It really helps.
And it's used extensively in that code lab
I mentioned which Rich is entering.
>>Johanni: [Inaudible]
>>Nick: Can you say that again you're a bit
>>Johanni: Okay, I'll speak closer to the
mic.
Is it still able to run the app on multiple
devices [inaudible] cause there's some things
like the way pop ups are canceled [inaudible]
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Johanni: [Inaudible]
>>Nick: Voice testing our own device.
[Pause]
>>Rich: I'm just driving this, sorry.
>>Matt: How about another question from the
moderator?
[Pause]
>>Sparky: Yeah, so, I'm not sure how far,
or where in the moderator, you guys were in
a hangout last week when I wasn't here so
I don't know which ones you've covered or
not.
>>Nick: Uh, Rich, you wanna look up?
>>Rich: Yep, one more word.
Alright,
[Pause]
>>Nick: Yeah, that.
So the question says, "[inaudible] with two
actions, stop and play, pause.
[inaudible] the list disappears when play,
pause" what?
I'm lost.
>>Rich: When you press stop the notifications
disappear but when you press play, pause the
notification with a new icon is sent with
a notification list stays open.
Are the two buttons at the bottom?
>>Nick: Yeah, so I think he's talking about
the new Jellybean notification APIs.
Is Krieger listening in?
He might be able to clear some of this up.
>>Al: I know the project he's talking about,
it's the open intents time sheet.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Al: He's still pushing some code is basically
what he's trying to do it have stop, stop
the task but not remove the notification from
the notification bar.
But what he's saying is when stop's pressed,
the notification is removed from the notification
bar.
>>Rich: Pause stops the notifications?
>>Al: Yeah.
>>Rich: Hm.
Seems reasonable.
[Laughs]
>>Nick: So it's an ongoing investigation for
a background service?
>>Al: What he, yeah, what is basically is
is a time tracking application and he's trying
to use the stop button to stop the tracking
of time rather than stop the application itself.
But he's saying the stop button removes the
notifications.
>>Nick: Yeah, is he using a builder to build
it up?
>>Al: I don't, I've asked him for the source
code and he's trying to get that across to
me so he might have it later today in which
case I won't use the moderator with that.
>>Nick: Yeah, that'd be interesting to look
at cause I know on the builder you can set
auto cancel which I do actually wonder if
it's balanced with service where cancel actually
removes the notification when you press stop.
So that'll be my first thing I'd look at.
The API change right toward [inaudible] there
used to be a window flag that you could set
to say whether it flows to the application
or not but I can't remember, so I'll have
to check.
But, yeah, it'd be nice to see the code that
behind this behavior.
>>Al: I'll try to get a link up in the moderator.
>>Nick: Is that one new [inaudible] APIs yet
>>Al: It's not.
>>Nick: It's probably one of the bigger developers
facing changes was JB.
JB is a lot of polished butteryness and smoothing
things out and not a ton of new developer
features that the API guys are pretty sweet.
So if you've not looked at those yet I highly
encourage you to take a look.
[Pause]
[Mumbling]
>>Nick: We should take another question.
>>Rich: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're stumbling across more of the questions
we took last week now but there was one
[Pause]
[Mumbling]
>>Sparky: Is it maybe the volume keys question?
>>Rich: Yeah, you can go for the volume keys
question there seems to be a lot of backwards
and forwards on that.
You wanna take that?
>>Sparky: So Yohan from the Netherlands says,
"I'm working on an app where he traps volume
up and volume down and on the Acer Iconious
7 inch tablet the buttons seem to be reversed,
any idea why?"
Um, I noticed that the buttons appeared to
be reversed on the Nexus 7 as well and, and,
and also on an LG tablet that I've got.
And then it just suddenly hit me, it's a portrait
device.
The 7 inch tablet is by default a portrait
device and when you hold it in portrait that
lower button actually is volume down but when
you turn it landscape, hitting that button
the right, makes the volume bar go to the
left.
So my thought is that it is intended to be
a landscape device and it's not remapping
the sense of the buttons when you change the
orientation of the device.
I think it should remap the sense of the buttons
as you change orientation but I don't know
that that's mandated by the platform or anything
like that.
I actually opened up a, I don't remember if
it was a bug or a feature request on Jellybean
that we should, in fact, change the sense
of the buttons as we change the sense of the
device.
That was my answer to that question.
>>Rich: I mean, it seems very strange when
you've got the app and the landscape across
the top [inaudible] you press the right gear
pedal and the gear goes down and the left
hand pedal, the display on the screen goes
the opposite way so that's very confusing.
I'm sure they'll change that [inaudible]
>>Nick: There's something to be said for the
expectation that this bit of the button always
turns the volume up, you know, you just always,
if you go away from that like it's a stable
experience right now, like I know that hitting
that always turns the volume up and they go
changing it around and flipping and reversing
it, I, I don't know.
I'm sure there's tons of user studies behind
this choice so I will leave that to wiser
and more tested people than I am.
>>Rich: Good choice.
>>Al: I get partly confused with which way
is up.
Um, how do you define which way is up with
the tablet when you hold it one way or whether
you hold it another way?
How do you define what the up button is?
If you are gonna have a consistent experience
one way up could be another way down.
>>Rich: yeah, it's just the graphics on the
screen move the other way to the variations
you push the button.
>>Sparky: I think there's fair room for argument
on both sides because I think it is reasonable
from a UX perspective to expect that the same
hardware affords, the same hardware thing
has the same result every time.
And that sort of runs contrary to the pressing
the right button makes the slider go right,
if you see what I mean.
>>Nick: Maybe we should just change it so
if you're in landscape the volume bar is like
vertical rather than horizontal and that'd
be way less confusing.
[Laughter]
>>Nick: Yeah, cause you're not touching on
the left and it's going right.
>>Rich: You have a second set of buttons here.
>>Nick: You touch here and it goes up.
Anyway.
>>Yohan: Sorry guys, I joined late.
>>Rich: Oh, we just answered your question.
>>Nick: Yeah.
[Laughter]
>>Yohan: I'll watch it later.
Maybe add a preference to reverse the effect
of the volume button
[Mumbling]
>>Al: You could, in theory, do it in applications
by detecting the orientation device and then
altering the action in response to volume
up and volume down.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: We'd like to keep it consistent across
the applications.
So we need to fix it in the platform if it
in an issue or we'll just accept that this
is
>>Nick: Change it.
Change it.
>>Yohan: Okay.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: Accept that it is right the way that
it is and you're just a bunch of monkeys.
>>Al: What are you actually capturing Yohan?
Is it actually for volume control or is it
something else?
>>Yohan: Yeah it's the volume control but
it's for, um, how do you say it, server.
So I'm controlling an external device.
It's basically we promote control in an app
[inaudible]
>>Rich: Okay, can you say anymore?
Is it Google TV or Nexus Q or anything?
[Laughter]
>>Yohan: But you could say, um, I could increase
the volume [inaudible].
But it was one particular device so I'll figure
it out.
>>Rich: Good.
I'm glad you'll figure it out.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: Few interruptions, right?
>>Nick: This is interesting app, did anyone
catch that new Twitter app Tweet Lanes that
came out over the weekend, I think it was,
which is using the volume keys to kind of
step onto the next tweet in streams so you
can sit there and tap, tap, tap and you don't
have to use the screen which is kind of interesting,
I thought.
I prefer scrolls smoothly, at the moment it
jumps which is a bit jarring.
I prefer to use smooth scroll 2, I think is
the API they use but interesting new app.
[Pause]
[Typing noise]
>>Nick: Go back to the moderator
>>Rich: I think we may have completed the
moderator.
>>Nick: Oh, interesting.
>>Rich: Let's have just another quick look
through the comments.
>>Sparky: There's some new ones that just
came in, I think.
>>Rich: In the moderator?
>>Sparky: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Oh, yeah.
Like, "Why Nexus devices have no SD card slot?
I'd like to buy a Nexus 7 but 16 Gig isn't
very much."
It's all about cost.
Adding card slots costs money.
Adding, making cases that can be opened up
costs money.
>>Nick: What about the cloud?
>>Rich: Yeah, there's a better answer to that
Sparky.
>>Nick: I was sure you were gonna say something
about the Cloud.
[Laughter]
>>Sparky: Oh, I knew I got it wrong.
>>Rich: Yeah, so technically it's probably
about cost but the message is about Cloud.
Why do you need, um
>>Nick: Yeah, I've been using the 8 Gig version
and I haven't really been using it too much,
I mean, music, a couple of films, a few games
and it's not too big of a deal, really, I
think I ran out once.
>>Rich: I'm the opposite.
I keep running out of space on the 8 gig.
I'd love to switch to the 16 but of course
you can just use the USB adaptor and put in
128 gig memory stick in the bottom, maybe
find a little tiny one, maybe wrap around
the back, find some kind of adaptor, accidental
hard drive.
But for the price
>>Sparky: What are you filling up an 8 gig
tablet with?
I mean I've got my entire music collection
and like a few dozen games and I think I've
got 6 gigs free.
>>Al: Enough movies for a flight to San Francisco
and back?
>>Rich: He's got 2 gigs of music to his name.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: That's crazy dude.
You must be using Google Cloud or something.
>>Sparky: I am using the Cloud.
>>Rich: Let me just show you my games on here.
Games these days are getting big, right?
>>Al: It's games for me
>>Rich: I've got Death Trigger, that's 600
megabytes.
Shadowland, that's a gigabyte.
I bought the games on sale; really, it's the
sales fault more than anything.
>>Nick: While we're talking about sales and
Nexus 7 please, please, please can everyone
use some kind of syncing mechanism to sync
progress between phones and tablets cause
I'm getting annoyed at having to play catch
up with my progress and pay for a game twice
on my phone and tablet depending on what I
have with me.
>>Al: You mean like the Google drive API that
the SDKs gonna come out?
>>Nick: That's a perfect segue about what
I was gonna say next.
[Laughter]
>>Al: Have you seen their t-shirts?
They have "I sync therefore I am" on them.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: I didn't catch those at IO.
>>Al: Yeah
[Laughter]
>>Al: I'll have to get me one of them.
That's a t-shirt I don't have, what's going
on?
[Laughter]
>>Al: I have it, Rich, this is scary.
You're usually the swag magnet.
>>Rich: Yeah, you're the magnet, that's fine.
Whatever.
Okay, so are there any more questions from
inside the hangout while we figure out what
else is on the moderator?
>>Sparky: I'll refer to one question from
a newcomer who said, "How long do the hangouts
usually last and are you planning on always
hosting them at 2 o'clock in the afternoon?"
Yes, they last an hour and they're always
gonna be at 2 o'clock in the afternoon Wednesday.
UK time, that's 3 o'clock in the afternoon
Central Europe time.
>>Nick: We had that last week and I answer
it different, I was like, "Well, they currently
are but is there any, you know, is it a bad
time for you?"
But I didn't hear anything back.
No one, just seem to say it was a fine time
so it's gonna stay the same.
>>Rich: We have a new single place we're coordinating
all of these hangouts across the products,
the Chrome hangouts, the GPlus hangouts, the
Android hangouts
>>Nick: There's other products?
>>Rich: There's other products, they don't
get green rooms like this.
And that's at developers dot Google dot Com
forward slash live.
Google did a live launch just before IO on
June the 18th and it's a single portal for
finding out all the details for all these
hangouts and you can post all the questions
into the hangouts in different time zones,
you can watch the hangouts, yay.
>>Nick: Which is incidentally why we didn't
use the events on GPlus, I think we're trying
to use live that's where all of the Google
club is, hangouts, office hours and so on
are gonna be hosted so [inaudible] really
>>Al: Is there any way of filtering this stuff
on live so I can only get Android stuff or
people can only get Chrome stuff?
>>Rich: There may not be yet but I know when
we create the events it says which product
it's for so I'm sure, because the developers
live site just went live so there's a whole
team still working on the functionality of
it and maybe that will be added.
>>Nick: [inaudible]
>>Rich: I can understand why you'd want to
filter the rest of that
>>Nick: Maybe we should use Gplus event, you
know, go into party mode
>>Rich: [inaudible]
[Laughter]
>>Nick: Everyone can take a photo of where
they are.
>>Al: I did run an event with hangouts so
it'll be interesting to see if there's pictures
of hangouts taking place in browsers on various
people's desktops.
>>Nick: Did anyone do it?
>>Al: There were people that said they were
coming and I think most of those came.
>>Nick: I'm gonna join your event now, place
a photo.
Talk amongst yourselves.
>>Rich: Someone's joining the hangout.
[Mumbling]
>>Rich: I'm just trying to add you into the
hangout [inaudible].
[Pause]
>>Rich: For some reason it's not letting me.
What have you done wrong?
[Laughs]
[Pause]
>>Nick: everyone's signing up for Al's GPlus
event.
>>Rich: Right.
>>Al: I've taken the first photos so hopefully
we can see how it comes out.
>>Sparky: I think we've got a new question
on the moderator here.
It says, "I'm working on building an amateur
new hardware device, can't find any guide
on how to customize system apps like the ones
that reference internal values and such.
For example, [inaudible]launcher."
I would say that your route there is to download
the source from the Android open source project
and built the social system.
Now, the actual, like the Google system, um,
services apps, those you can't get from AOSP
but if you're gonna go that route then you
enter into a partnership with Google and then
maybe the PDK will be made available to you,
the new thing that we announced at Google
IO to help give hardware manufacturers who
are working on those devices with the Google
added services to get early access to upcoming
features on the platform.
>>Al: It might also be worth mentioning the
CTS which is the set of which apps, uh, which
devices need to pass in order to be considered
Android compatible.
So if they are developing a new device, it
is well worth getting a hold of the CTS to
make sure they're not doing anything that
goes and takes that device outside the test
suite and that's the compatibility definition.
>>Rich: How can you find the CTS?
>>Al: The CTS is part of the Android open
source project and you can download it to
serve part the bundles when you follow the
instructions at source dot Android dot com.
[Mumbling]
[Laughter]
>>Sparky: And if you think that the CTS does
not require a certain functionality that it
ought to then you can propose a new test and
maybe even write it and offer it as a patch
and maybe they'll accept it into CTS for the
next round.
>>Rich: Hm, do we have
[pause]
>>Al: Do we have a frozen screen?
[Laughs]
>>Sparky: We do.
[Laughter]
[Pause]
>>Sparky: And it's such a flattering one too.
[Laughter]
>>Rich: Don't know what happened there.
Um, there's a question come through the Gplus
chat from Boyd saying that he's not a developer
but is there, perhaps, a sample pack with
web view possibilities and what can I do to
optimize HML5 for Android to work nice and
smoothly?
Um, yeah, there's a few things, first of all
writing Android application that uses a web
view is pretty simple, you just drag a web
view onto there and stop floating your HTML.
You do still have to use the development tool
environment whether it's Eclipse or IntelliJ.
There are some third party tools which you
can use, word facilitate, not using the developer
[Pause]
>>Rich: Shouldn't recommend using any one
over any of the other ones of those you can
just do a Google search for web development
on Android and hopefully you'll come across
those products.
But if you don't want to write an Android
app with web view it's all pretty simple.
It gets a little more complicated when you're
looking at making it super smooth because
the hardware acceleration of the web view
has varied throughout various versions of
Android.
There wasn't really in Gingerbread, with Honeycomb
we added some high acceleration for web view
but some of the functionality of the web view
wasn't hardware accelerated.
We have an IO talk and some details you can
look for on the internet about what is hardware
accelerated and what isn't.
It improved a bit in Ice Cream Sandwich but
it's improved massively in Jellybean.
The Jellybean web view has good hardware acceleration
on; it fixes many of the issues you would
have seen in the Ice Cream Sandwich and higher
and other web views.
So the simplest way is to not use hardware
acceleration at all but you won't get great
performance.
The best way is to optimize it for your own
Gingerbread, then Honeycomb and Ice Cream
Sandwich and also Jellybean on top.
Maybe do hardware acceleration on Jellybean
and not on the previous ones.
It's gonna be more consistent from now on.
That was a slightly distinct story for each
of the platforms with all that.
>>Sparky: I don't know if I would recommend
a web view for like really challenging stuff
that needs acceleration anyway.
I think, a web app is a way to get, sort of,
a lowest common denominator application that
runs on as many disparate platforms as possible
>>Matt: Preach it.
>>Sparky: but it's never gonna be best in
class on any of them.
>>Rich: Sure, the guy who asked the question
is a web developer so
[Laughs]
>>Rich: Clearly his easiest routes market
but we would definitely advocate using of
major views and widgets, things like that.
>>Nick: It'd just be a way of limitations
in a web view, you're only gonna get so far.
When you stack all your layers of abstraction
on top of each other then yeah, you're gonna
have some limitations.
And I certainly never found a web app which
is as smooth as or couldn't be approved by
doing such a thing.
>>Al: There was a talk at IO this year about
making high performance mobile web apps.
I'll stick a link to that in the comments
but I've heard from people who have used the
evil apple IOS version of the Facebook app
which is purely a web app that is probably
one of the most dire user experiences they've
ever had.
So it's kind of setting the tone for a Facebook
on a apple device come out with something
that's dire, there's not a lot you can do
to improve it.
>>Nick: I mean, I'm not saying there's no
call for it.
I mean, Gmail, for example, uses web views
to render some of its content and that's one
of my favorite apps of all time.
So I'm not saying there's no place for it
I'm just saying if you're trying to something
really, really kind of responsive and interactive
and flashy then you're gonna kind of run up
against the limits of what it can do.
>>Matt: Plus you've got users expectations
of downloading an app from the store and they're
gonna be at a point where [inaudible]
>>Rich: Yeah, definitely, very valid points,
both Matt and Nick.
Text layout in any app, using a web view is
gonna be one of the easiest ways of doing
that especially when trying to wrap text around
images and do custom layouts.
But I still put the challenge out there to
anyone who wants to produce a web based app
for Android, a web app, then hand it over
and see if we can tell whether or not it's
a web app.
Every time you pick one up, to us, it's instantly
obvious that it's a web app, the scrolling
is not right, I'm trying to bounce back in
Java Script or force field in Android in Java
Script, it's gonna be tricky.
Trying to make anything that looks native
or feels, tracks the finger like a view pager,
like that kind of views, it's just tricky
on the web without it being janky and slow.
So, good luck, but I still have hopes for
people being up to developing web technologies
>>Nick: We're Android fan boys so we're gonna
be native all the way.
>>Rich: And make apps which we can tell aren't
native
>>Nick: That's only one.
>>Rich: Feel free to make it just make it
so I can't tell.
[Laughter]
>>Nick: If we've got a bit of time left, I
would like to hear from Johanni who won a
hack-a-thon this weekend.
We have an interesting hack, I was wondering
if you might be able to describe it to us?
>>Johanni: Sure, so we, weren't the only ones,
but we won the Google [inaudible]
>>Rich: Speak up.
>>Johanni: OK, so we won the Google category
of the hack with YouTube and another Google
team.
[Inaudible]London.
So what we built, we built, basically we stole
the idea from the Nexus Q because the Nexus
Q's not gonna come here so we built one for
us Europeans.
So we built a Google TV application which
was basically just a dummy player so when
you fire up the Google TV app it shows the
UR code.
Then we have the phone applications and public
applications which you can use to scan the
UR codes and join the party and everyone who
scans the same UR code, size, product, same
party and then you can just search YouTube
videos on put them on a common playlist.
And the Google TV application will just play
the playlist until it runs out.
[Inaudible].
>>Nick: So this easy to do, you usually [inaudible]
YouTube player API, so basically
>>Male #10: Yeah, new player API so we can
actually invent the player and videos and
the application and not launch the YouTube
player.
We used the Google Cloud method so people
don't have to use wifi [inaudible] then we
used the, we rebuilt the application from
a couple of regular applications.
We [inaudible] tablet API,
>>Rich: Good.
>>Nick: Is that using the new template style?
>>Male #10: No because the templates only
available if you ask apple [inaudible].
>>Nick: Yeah, so we've got the app [inaudible]
we didn't have Ice Cream Sandwich or anything.
Well he says he built it but I haven't seen
a link in Playstore yet so
>>Male #10: I sent it a case to match so you
can see
>>Nick: In your face, quite certainly.
>>Al: So, um, your new, your new ego, slogan,
isn't it Nick?
No Playstore link?
Never happened.
[Laughter]
>>Nick: Well, I think that just about brings
us to a close.
So unless there's any burning questions that
you guys have been chomping at the bit to
ask but haven't been able to get a word in
edgewise then I think we might draw this session
to a close.
So thank you very much everyone who joined
us live
>>Al: You asked if anyone had any burning
questions, maybe someone has.
Does anyone have any burning questions?
So the last people that joined want to ask
anything?
>>Nick: I paused for half a second.
>>Rich: Half a second, I know, but there might
be lag
[Laughter]
>>Rich: It should be like does anyone have
any questions before we wrap up today?
Okay you should carry on anyway.
Sorry for the interruption.
So your normal service shall resume shortly
[Laughter]
>>Nick: I was just saying thank you everyone
for joining us on the live stream and watching
on YouTube later on, hi people in the future,
but we'll do this every week so 2 pm UK time
every Wednesday.
See you next time!
>>Al: Bye guys.
>>Rich: Cheers, bye everyone, thanks for coming
in and watching on YouTube.